walk him to this video and playing black
in a 15 minute rapid game against plane
from the UK d 4 okay let's let's play
something else I usually try to play my
book repertoire the news I bogo but he
went for Bishop f4 the the London sister
it's not down it's not the most
inspiring choice okay he played it with
the delayed um Knight f3 this is
interesting because in this fashion he
prevents me from playing Bishop f5 here
and he's got the idea to play you fall
g6e for I think is possible way to play
this is why I'm I played something else
so should I just get get the bishop yeah
let's let's get the bishop
g5 is what I'm talking about take it
yeah let's do that yeah this is a funny
funny trick but night f-4s quite often a
good answer not sure if it is a good one
at this point but don't spend too much
time I'm always glad to somehow mix it
up against the London it's simply that
this cliche that players to play that
want to have some rather dull risk-free
position this cliche is very often true
so if you are able to mix it up it's
often a good idea I have my doubts about
the objective quality in here of black
specks position atria serve I never know
now it's coming age 3 is a very weird
news
because f4 I mean how do you protect the
phone oh gee 3 i'm going to play mukajee
8 and ask you what are you doing then f5
was answered by Queen f4 which just
picks up the earth porn h3 is really
strange move so he just gives up the
pawn I'm glad to take it it's not just a
pawn it's a very important supporter of
the center and it's also a Bishop f5
coming and so Bishop f5 on yeah this is
here kept Bishop f5 f5 maybe maybe
weakens the queenside a bit too much
you know what to play against this
Bishop f5 queen bee too yeah this is not
not too too convincing
I'm not very well developed this is this
is an issue but of course then he will
have problems with his King King safety
as well where is he going to to Castle
yeah okay his short Cassilis never
really really safe either so let's win
this tempo him what I was afraid of a
bit as Queen B to takes Queen takes long
castles and my king I don't know but
it's not not dangerous the bishop is
protecting be one it's not even he's not
considering that
okay so what what am I going to do there
are many good ideas here even if 5s is a
very interesting idea to to break it up
like with the utmost for co e 5 because
my place on the dark square so not
considering c4 that it is hanging 'if
I've be takes e4 he takes d4 not
interesting
I take be three
hmm
look G 850 many interesting movie
already 35 has probably nonsense after a
four don't think I want to do that I'm
not sure that take and he actually takes
with the night hmm yeah the Queen I
don't want to give a match for I mean
it's a it's I want to keep the extra
phone don't really want to return it so
quickly we go rook g8 be takes e4 look G
to C D 5 so this is ridiculous
you favors someone that that looks so
powerful
yeah but it's probably not not really
working
and if I go b5 this really a 4am this is
some an issue
ok so I expect him to take with the
night to get the pawn back but um ok I
still have a nice position it's not like
I really was thinking I'm trying getting
a really quick win even not just a good
position so this didn't didn't
materialize now I cannot keep the pawn
but it's not not a big problem i have
the two bishops and they'll have to see
pawn to play against
now look at this Bishop e3 this is the
the main the main point it's not just
two bishops it's two bishops that
actually do something in relation to the
weaknesses in the position
okay so he probably will aim to play c4
yeah rook c8 on da it now let's go up
said yeah I think I'm threatening to
move the night to to tie down the porn
he needs to be able to place you for now
otherwise it's a it's really ugly but ok
see for I take a play night before yeah
thats it's just a good position to
bishops in a wide open in a wide open
game
check there are no a 2 is some detect
not threatening to take it immediately
but it it will happen maybe just Roxy to
the cell is good oh very a violent way
to try to get out of trouble here how to
how to play that I could actually take I
mean look a 193 it's not bad
but if I go a six where are you going is
six Bishop e2 oopsie to black come on
this is good so let's be let's be good
here at least not get into really bad
time travel or maybe just 95 I just
discovered this idea should have seen
this before 93
I'm still may be Bishop a three now
Bishop F 393 Bishop d7 yeah but it's it
won't be enough really
hmm I don't really see him the Bishop's
dominator I mean of course he has got
moves but nothing that really helps him
much besides 93 there's also not see
three sm as a threat
maybe rooks it to now 5 is not really
not really a problem
yeah it looks it looks like an active
could move f5 I can I can just ignore
really it's not it's not a problem
rookie one he must must play and then I
was I was planning to just take it
hmm
didn't see that okay need to take you
first camp is he able to play rookie six
maybe is
I India he needs the player okay six I
mean if you don't do that it's it's just
just completely over not sure that it is
what I'm technically I will be six okay
vigo be 5a sir is one issue with the
smooth and Bishop g8
and Bishop g8 next first is check and
then Bishop g8 yeah it must be chaste be
better really be five is also possible
but then we gauge six no no just the
check and then Bishop GA it should be
good skewering the Rugen bishop
I hope that this picks up the c-4 bishop
as planned
yeah but I'm gonna piss at the end f8 is
protected by this bishop on a three
yeah it was just too much the two
bishops and this open positions are very
hard to hard to battle
yeah I think at the end he just
overlooked that III is still protecting
the rukon evade
white resigned no it's just just a piece
yeah h3 you are so amazingly amazingly
bad news but oh Bishop a3 I can play the
sugar 3 still I mean it's still bad for
h3 but this would have been better
Bishop f3 winning a tempo not losing the
pawn immediately and this just gave a
give it away check we are the compass a
very materialistic it should be too I
didn't consider this there should be two
because of c-4 but maybe I'm I'm not
understanding things how come wants to
play like that yeah okay I didn't think
about Blanca salts really yeah this is
strong it just gets lost okay but my
move wasn't bad I'm pretty sure about
that check yeah this is some probably
probably very good a bishop c3 is better
I Bishop c2 is better ah yeah I am this
is very strong even who hair do you go
you get this
and at the end he's got got this one
yeah why this what is in terrible shape
what I did skep the advantage but wasn't
the most precise way to play yeah this
is not working but I hadn't hadn't
really seen it before but now it's it's
just a piece I don't really believe that
that this is too great maybe Knight f3
here it's instead of h3 yeah it's just
complicated and a bit messy this
position but this is an in general a
good way to play against the London if
you want to complicate matters it worked
in this game as well okay thanks for
watching